something entirely new entirely
different for the MCU a group of
immortals who've been on earth for
thirty five thousand years they've been
there amongst the MCU we haven't met
them before this film is full Jack Kirby
[Applause]
Hebrew one is Charlie I've gotten a lot
of requests to do a video about Marvel's
Eternals movie probably the most
important movie during Marvel phase four
some of the other movies like Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
are also critical for world building aka
developing the multiverse is a big story
device for future movies to take
advantage of but the Eternals is
critical for setting up what the next
big fan OHS level threat is going to be
in there's a very important reason why
they didn't help out during Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame because
there's some of the most powerful people
on planet earth so why wouldn't they
help out if something that big was
happening and why haven't they helped
out before there's really good reasons
for that and a lot of it has to do with
the comic book story that they're basing
the Eternals movie on so we'll break it
all down there's a new brand of that
Avengers endgames special box set
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best Marvel phase 4 word theory on the
video so if you're not familiar with the
backstory of the Eternals they're
actually this really weird obscure group
in the comics they pop up every once in
a while they're been a couple miniseries
they've had a couple of their own solo
titles but they never been quite as
popular as say like the x-men the
Fantastic Four or any of the other big
teams like The Avengers and there's a
lot of complicated backstory that
overlaps a little bit with what's going
on with the Inhumans but if you haven't
been reading it they've actually just
published what they call a history of
the Marvel Universe by Mark Waid that
sort of makes sense of it in a much
simpler way it all starts with a cosmic
entity eternity which represents the
body of the multiverse there's this
consciousness this grand design behind
everything
it creates the Celestials at the dawn of
the multiverse they go out and start
experimenting on planets creating life
then they come back to visit it
periodically to see if their experiment
has borne fruit there's the flashback
during the first guardians of the galaxy
movie where you see Isan the searcher
one of the Celeste
coming back to coal a planet that he's
experimented on deeming it a failure
when the Celestials come to judge a
planet it's called the celestial host so
the first celestial host comes to Planet
Earth they experiment on primitive
humans turning them into the Eternals
making them genetically perfect giving
them all kinds of celestial abilities
and powers that they then learn about
and hone over the millennia that they're
alive one of the big changes that the
movie is making to the Eternals
characters is that they're saying they
run thirty-five thousand years old
instead of a million years old like they
are in the comics once they're done the
Eternals leave and every once in a while
they come back to judge them so the
celestial host will come back to see
what's become of their creation in the
MCU in the present day the reason why
all the characters are still alive not
counting fan o's with the Infinity
Gauntlet trying to snap everyone away is
because the celestial host when it comes
across the ages has allowed the earth to
continue to exist so they're so powerful
and so influential on human history why
didn't they show up for Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame well a
lot of it has to do with the plot of
Neil Gaiman's Eternals run which
interestingly enough ties them to the
Avengers story so that's actually really
important for the Eternals movie two is
that after we've had 22 Marvel films you
have to explain why these characters are
such a big deal and why they've been
around this whole time but we haven't
seen them until now that's where you get
to the Neil Gaiman Eternals run that
sort of weaves them in with the history
of the Avengers but also explains why
they're not around in present-day
helping the Avengers out with other big
challenges one of the reasons why the
Eternals are so long-lived is because of
their own natural powers that they
learned to hone they learned to use the
celestial energy given to them by the
Celestials themselves but they also can
reincarnate that's one of their biggest
powers no matter how they die or how
many times they die they reincarnate
inside a special celestial sarcophagus
underneath Antarctica but the reason why
people in present day have never heard
about the Eternals and why the Avengers
have never seen them why nobody's
talking about them why they didn't show
up during Avengers infinity war is
because during this Neil Gaiman run most
of the Eternals don't realize that there
are Eternals their memories have been
wiped so during this Neil Gaiman story
you have a bunch of Eternals in
day leading normal human lives walking
around you can imagine that happening
around Avengers infinity war then having
families just going about their day
Thanos snaps every one-half of all life
vanishes then the Hulk snaps everyone
back and they all come back the Eternals
that were snapped then start to remember
who they are what their powers are in
what their history is in the Neil Gaiman
story it's Icarus who's being played by
Richard Madden in the movie sort of one
of the main characters is one of the few
people that starts to remember his life
as an eternal in present day he goes to
a doctor and it turns out the doctor is
also in eternal - who hasn't quite
started to remember yet but slowly a
group of villains find Icarus and
torture him to try and get information
out of him he dies is reincarnated in
their special celestial sarcophagus in
all of his memories come back then
separately a group of eternals is
attacked and they used their powers
instinctively and start to realize who
they are including the deviants the
villains - but here's the really cool
connection to Iron Man The Avengers even
Howard Stark in present day one of the
Eternals is named thena she's being
played by Angelina Jolie in present day
she works as a weapons designer for
Stark Industries so you have to imagine
in Angelina Jolie working for Howard
Stark then Tony Stark just being this
brilliant scientist coming up with these
really cool designs not knowing that
she's secretly this super powerful being
the big threat of the story though is
the return of the celestial host so the
group of villains in the story tried to
awaken the slumbering eternal so that
will judge earth and wipe everyone from
existence so you're on your way to your
next Thanos level threat which really is
the return of the celestial host the
Celestials the most powerful beings in
the universe Galactus when he comes into
the MCU
will be a celestial just like ego the
Living Planet was a celestial think
about how bad one of them was Isan the
searcher and the guardians of the galaxy
flashback how bad was ego the Living
Planet by himself now imagine an entire
team of them working together to wipe
you from existence
we are forever
[Music]
the Eternals themselves are not powerful
enough to kill Celestials but they can
convince them that humanity is worthy of
continuing to exist you can't really
defeat a celestial without other crazy
celestial tech like Iron Man's
god-killer armor is basically a
celestial version of his Iron Man armor
most likely scenario if the Eternals
franchise is as successful as other
Marvel franchises you will build up to
that celestial host arriving in whatever
third big film that will be there
Ragnarok level moment the Eternals are
powerful enough characters that you have
to build up to a threat that's that big
it's like a Thor movie Thor one of the
most powerful characters in the MCU has
to face villains that are more powerful
than him and that means they had to be
God level scale so hopefully that
explains how the Eternals backstory
connects with the Avengers in present
day how they've been around this whole
time but we haven't seen them yet and
why they didn't help out fight during
Avengers infinity war in Avengers end
game imagine them turning that into a
joke in the next Avengers film we just
saved the universe a couple years ago
what have you guys done recently we've
been around for the last 35 thousand
years and we're gonna teach you how to
survive the Celestials which are way
worse than anything you've seen so far
and despite all the recent bad news
about the spider-man character in the
MCU the spider-man post-credit scene
also explains kind of what's coming with
this next major celestial host in the
next six to seven years quick spoiler
warning for the spider-man far from home
post credits scene if you haven't seen
that movie yet but we need to talk about
what happens with Nick Fury at the very
end of that movie part of the reason why
Nick Fury is now living in outer space
on the sword Space Station from the
comics is because they're gonna be much
more space space cosmic threats during
Marvel phase 4 phase 5 phase 6 and
Beyond the return of the celestial host
is a way long-term project it's not
going to happen for a long time but
we'll get a teaser for that during the
flashbacks in the Eternals movie when
they show the first celestial host
coming to Planet Earth to actually
create the Eternals characters that's
actually what you're seeing here and all
this concept art and the teasers they
showed off a comic-con there are clouds
down at the bottom of this picture to
give you an idea for the scale of how
big they are because you don't really
get a sense for that in Isan the
searcher here during this guardians
flashback
you can kind of see people running
really close to the frame this is their
knees hitting the clouds that's how big
they are that's why it's so hard for the
Avengers to fight the Celestials because
they've already atomized the Infinity
stones in present day so there's no
Infinity Gauntlet for them to assemble
getting to the Fantastic Four of it all
that's where we spent up to cosmic
Fantastic Four Silver Surfer Galactus
crossover so it's all coming together in
a much bigger more cosmic way during
phase four the big Marvel phase four d23
panel is this weekend we're gonna get a
bunch of trailers for everything but
we'll also get more information about
the Eternals movie what's happening with
the other movies like Doctor Strange the
multiverse of madness
maybe Marvel phase 5 outside chance we
learn about Fantastic Four and x-men
Deadpool stuff happening I'll do videos
for all of it and I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post my new Marvel video
everybody click here to learn how Marvel
can still save spider-man in the MCU and
everybody click here to learn about why
the Russos are talking about a nova
scene and Avengers endgame thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]